try to put those into the q a as i said
uh and next we're going to do a quick
poll we'll do you doing one at the
beginning one at the end
and this
first poll is pretty straightforward
just want to give brad an idea of how
much work experience you have to give
him a feel for the audience
we also include a question on how you're
doing today because during the pandemic
with all the stresses of lockdowns and
isolation we
want to check in with everybody's
mood
so we'll give you about 20 more seconds
please enter your
responses if you're watching on youtube
or linkedin you can put comments
otherwise you have a widget that you can
finish and it's five
four
three
two
one
and i will share the result
and the pulse up poll result
shows that
the biggest cohort today about a third
of the audience are people with more
than 10 years of experience
and the rest of the audience is
distributed
among the other experience levels so we
have a fairly seasoned and experienced
audience today brad
it's good that's unusual
and also
it's good to see that
most people are doing well
some people are in the middle of the
people who are
could be doing better we hope that
this educational opportunity and what
brad's going to share with you is
something that'll help you focus on your
future so
with that said
let's go ahead and introduce brad
as i mentioned he's the co-founder of at
alice's he's an author and speaker
writes columns for search engine land
has written the book advanced google
adwords
keynoted and spoken at 125
conferences
and led more than 100 google ad seminars
and
he is the chair of our
pay-per-click
digital marketing program at
learn and we're very pleased to have him
here today
welcome brad and thanks all right thank
you stuart
so for for everyone today we're going to
talk about strategic planning now this
is not the sexy topic of quality score
it's not the creative topic of
ad testing and ad creation and fun stuff
it at times is sort of a mundane topic
but it is an incredibly important one
what it does is it sets you up for
success in accounts it makes sure that
your clients are getting what they want
that your boss is happy
and that everyone's working from the
same set of kpis and information and so
i in many ways it's a lot of background
work
if you're a paid search analyst and you
sort of look at that strategy position
this is the kind of information which
lets you sort of advance in that career
towards that strategist
so when we often look at how people set
up accounts and talk about things and
look at stuff there's really kind of two
groups
there there's the group that kind of the
ad hoc way and there they say hey mr
client mrs client what do you do
um and they have a little conversation
and then they're off and running
and they don't sit back and say how do
we need to measure what systems need to
be integrated what's this whole thing
right and then you got the group that
says we should be very strategic about
this
as you can guess being strategic takes a
bit more time
their retention rate and their client
happiness is generally much higher now
in this conversation we're just going to
say client and if you're in house that's
often your boss it could be a different
department if your agency of course it
is a client um it's the easy way to use
one word for everything
we're also going to have a couple
handouts um for this so there's sort of
a sample strategic documentation and a
sample marketing plan um there's written
for like you know acne plumbing
from an example company that would give
you an idea of layouts and things and
then how sort of moves forwards
as well as a lot of questions to talk
about with your your company and your
clients as you sort of walk through this
exercise
so everything starts
with the course
an interview with the client themselves
and initially right we want to get is
this overall basic understanding of the
business
right their description their services
and products so forth
and why we really want to look at the
business aspect here
is that a lot of companies are actually
do multiple things so for instance i
lived in chicago for a while and if
you're a roofer in chicago repair
fixtures what not you can't do it in the
winter time because it's just too cold
it's too windy so forth so that same
company becomes basement refinishers in
this in the wintertime right so there's
summer roofers uh winter refinishers and
that's where understanding just how the
business kind of makes money is a really
important question
so you'll often hear people say yeah we
just want some more leads
but no one wants leads right they want
qualified leads they want marketing
qualified leads but again in the end
it's how do you make money
and by understanding the money flow
right it lets you understand okay this
is the type of tracking we need to put
into place this is how you're gonna
ultimately judge us on certain things
and then we want priority orders if they
sell a thousand products to have 20
services
there's probably some they prioritize
right so you're making sure you're on
the same page with the client
and then what is their budget right and
is it flexible
this is so important because if a
company says yeah we have a ten thousand
dollar month budget
well what happens if suddenly there's a
boom in their business can they be
flexible on it or do they say here are
annual budgets a million dollars but
it's okay to spend a lot less in the
beginning and spend more on that in the
end right so you can be flexible month
to month so what does that look like
because can you take advantage of
opportunities
and do they do a strict this is our
monthly budget which means you have to
be very careful about your allocation a
little more flexible with it right these
are these overall questions that kind of
frame the other conversations that are
happening
and once we have this we we want to
learn from that all right there's a lot
clients have a lot of information a lot
of good stuff yeah maybe they've not
managed paid search they did a terrible
job doesn't mean they don't understand
their business
so you know what did they do before was
it successful what was not success right
avoid some pitfalls
would certain overall swot analysis
right their strength weakness
opportunity threat analysis
for their own business
they know this for the competitors
now
i would say half the time if i ask
someone who are their competitors
and i make a list and then i go to
auction insights which in google tells
you who you actually compete against in
auctions
i'd say 50 only half the competitors are
actually there and that there's often a
different company who is truly their top
competitor right so we want to see
this is what they do and how what
they're good at and then here's what the
competition is good at are there easy
gaps to manage in that
now past that
who's your ideal customer right
important question for them
now you have to start somewhere right so
you're going to start with with this
overall information for personas
thinking about keywords who should the
ads be speaking to
what audiences need to be made do you
want to use demographic targeting
and then while we have to make these
assumptions that the client is correct
to start with right these are also the
things we're going to make a note of
that once we have data we want to check
it
i've seen many times like here's my
ideal customer profile and we see out
wires that sit in various spots that
weren't covered right so you have this
initial information
and then you check against it to make
refinements but you can't make a
refinement if you don't really know what
you're checking against to begin with
because often it's conversation the
client saying did you know this is also
a good group for you
now if you want to be truly impressive
and blew everyone away you can even do
persona workups right so this is for a
a telco a company that does you know
cell phone internet cable type stuff
and they have different types of groups
each group
buys the same thing whether it's
internet access cable tv they buy the
same product
the reason they buy it is substantially
different
therefore with your same keywords some
audience targeting on it you can make
custom ads to different groups right and
this is the kind of thing that we want
to sort of look at long term because it
really helps us maybe we can't start
with all this yet but we know here's
where we want to go here's that future
plan of expansion
we start here we look at personas based
upon your data and then we're going to
adjust things
because it's not just what do you build
and how do you start right the
refinement part is incredibly important
as well and having that plan of here's
what we do post launch
is really important aspect
now the long conversation right you
often have with companies
is right here
what's your buying cycle look like
if someone is in
b2b
they might have a really long buying
cycle
this affects your conversion windows
this affects what kind of touch points
you need to track
this affects the conversions you should
be using right so this is a really
important conversation when we think
about conversion tracking or you got to
put in place
what should we be tracking
if it's a six-month buying cycle on a
b2b company
yeah you could put in the sales after
six months it'll do you any good all
right you're not going to use it that
much
so then it's all right what can we
measure to optimize from and then how do
we make the steps we can do in
reasonable time frames better over time
right so this will also start to tell us
do we need to do multi-systems
integration do we not need to worry
about that
does the buying cycle change by device
it's still really common for people to
research on a phone buying a computer
but especially if you get into
configuration options and some more
advanced things right they make their
notes on phones but that's not where
they buy the buy comes from
and then you know does the buying cycle
change by different products or services
so this will be a while
and you're starting to understand the
technical aspect
you also have to understand their
resource constraints
so do they have a developer on staff who
can just do this
are you going to have to give them more
instructions on how to combine some
systems together
if so
is that part of your either it's sla or
your contract that you're not just
managing but you're doing some dev stuff
for landing page work or what not in
that
because one of the the fears of agencies
especially is scope creep right where
someone says yeah we only need you to
run our marketing campaigns
and then you're like all right we'll run
your marketing campaign here's our
contract and it's signed and suddenly
like oh yeah we don't track that you're
like okay you need to install phone call
tracking well how do we do that
all right so here's how we have vendor
conversations and the technology used
well can you do that for us
and and suddenly you went from a
contract that is just about
you know managing the marketing
to all these other things you're doing
that you might not be you're not being
uh paid for
so it's important to really understand
these options beforehand to know what
you're getting into
and then our marketing details right
this is going to start getting into very
specific numbers
how many leads or sales do you want a
month do you have a point you can
overwhelm your sales staff
i do one years of sales staff actually
work
what's your cpa target to your robots
targets how does this change by season
right are there are all these points
really being measured
and then we've got
what do you consider a successful
account this is one of my absolute
favorite questions to ask someone right
what do you deem as success because they
could say you know we want 50 leads a
month and a 25 cpa and we're all happy
they and but they're going to measure
success by
closed sales
well if they're measuring success by
close sales and you're optimizing to
leads
you could do a great job and still get
fired because maybe these leads aren't
marketing qualified or sales qualified
and you're working from the wrong
numbers
right so that single question what do
you consider a successful account
make sure what you're doing
lines up with what they're doing
right then
the second part because you may have one
liaison in the company who is kind of
doing the day-to-day but they may not be
signing the contracts and renewing the
contracts
so then the other part you really want
to ask is the person who funds the
account renews the account what do they
consider success
it might be different
maybe the person who renews the account
gets a bonus if you sell a hundred
thousand widgets and if you're trying to
sell you know some other product and not
the widgets they may not be happy in the
end even though you hit the goal set out
for you
and so this is a little bit of politics
right looking in the company and who's
doing what
but
it's really important if the company has
five departments
right just each department give
different funds and therefore each
department has different kpi setup and
that you're unaware of
and so getting into these specifics
ensures that you're building and
managing accounts to what will keep your
job right what will keep someone funding
this account you don't lose the client
and make everyone happy in the end
and it is i can't count the times i've
seen an agency do an amazing job
managing something
and still lose the client
and it was usually one of these two
questions the person the day-to-day
liaison
the different departments or the person
who who funds the account right
had different metrics for success
so
clearly this is a very important
question to really sort of dig into
now we think okay we have an idea of
what you do
and so forth so we need to start
thinking about budget planning
right which is insights into our
organization as well
so what's monthly budget
um is monthly budget does it change
is it monthly because they have co-op
marketing dollars you need to think
about
if someone's a franchise they'll call it
marketing dollars
do they need reports on how their money
was spent
if so then you can't just bundle all the
money together in a single campaign you
might need different campaigns for
different budget allocations coming in
from either different apartments or
different franchise locations what not
uh us funding happened by a product line
or a service line
right so this is a really part of aspect
an important part of aspect of campaign
organization
how often are budgets reviewed
so we see companies who look at their
budgets weekly in the poor agencies who
have to try to manage to a different
weekly target
it's really tough some do
annual budgets right so what does this
look like and then again flexibility in
budgets really important how flexible
can you be
so then
where do they want to advertise
and a lot of comes like we can just do
worldwide right and we we can ship
anywhere we can sell anywhere
and so worldwide is fine with us
and if you say okay let's do worldwide
you'll see a lot of countries
underperform right some will overform
some underperformance law of averages
and then later on they're like well you
know what really
germany and slovenia are our top two
countries
and we really want to focus our budget
there and then we overflow to uk and
united states
well okay that's something really
important to change beforehand
that are there regional considerations
so this affects that location targeting
right and do you need to do budgets by
that location
seasonality right another big question
so
it's easier for you to go look at google
trends and see how different keywords
change in seasons over time the client
will have insights into
what this season is how people plan what
people are looking for when they get new
stock in when they're a little
overslammed with phone calls that they
you know maybe need a little less leads
now because this season people all have
this particular issue therefore we get
more calls to this
right are there days you need to
highlight on the calendar
because it is your job to do the
marketing which means if the client
forgets to tell you about a day and it
passes
you might get blamed even though they
never told you right so that gets into
that planning aspect of here's highlight
days that we want to look at beforehand
right that gets into budget planning
again
and so let's see it's lost back
everybody has seasons right it doesn't
matter what you do there's better and
worse times of the year
or better in different weather
conditions you know various conditions
so
what do those things look like
now the really boring part that is
incredibly important
restrictions and what you can do
okay so do they have legal or brand
restrictions
you may have keywords you can't use
now
it may not be you can't use the keywords
you may be you can't show ads for these
search terms which means you have to
proactively add negative keywords maybe
they don't have certain trademarks
you're allowed to use they can't make
certain claims you get into
a lot of the supplement or gambling
industries and so forth but there's a
lot of claims that they can't make in
the ads or the pages or gets them in
legal trouble they often know what these
are
do ads and keywords can be approved by
legal or brand right and so if they're
going to review everything before you
can make it live
this lets you know you probably need to
set up a schedule
so that you have to talk to them okay
you can review 100 new ads a week so
we'll send you every monday we send you
100 new ads to review this week or
whatever the numbers are
right and that if someone says to you
hey we have this brand new promotion
that's going to go live in three days
right well it's not that you have to
jump to work right your question really
is can legal and branding approve it
fast enough
right that that sort of gets into that
question when they have those last
second urgent things that need to be
done can it actually be done and they
have to get legal and branding to move
on that
other blackout regions a lot of times if
your insurance your licensed businesses
your legal your franchises you have
regions you can't advertise in you're
not licensed in and so that gets right
into negative geographies before you
even start
and then other other restrictions right
we'll see some companies that have
full brand control over color palettes
and images they need
other times you don't have that
other things that must be updated on
regular basis a mortgage industry but
it's common that aprs need to be updated
well if they need to update apr's
regular basis
that tells you in your structure
you probably want to use ad customizers
as part of your overall system of what
how updates happen and how information
gets pulled
right so all these different questions
affect your workflow considerably and
need to have them again beforehand to
figure things out
the website
so the big question is who controls the
website
a lot of companies maybe they own their
website but they use a different company
who does updates and so maybe things
can't change quite as fast or
to do a change to a code they have to
submit it to somewhere else right we
have a client right now they're
switching cms's finally
every time they want to do a landing
page update it cost them three thousand
dollars
so if you're like hey we want to make a
slight tweak to the conversion code to
also pull in these additional q values
their their first question is is it
worth three thousand dollars
because if it's not they want to bundle
all the things together and say let's
bundle all the changes so we submit them
all at once right versus individually
if it's landing page testing again are
you doing it are you going to use
unbounce or some third-party
platform to make pages right so that
tells you again
are you getting paid to do that right
can they make microsites we see some
companies you know we need a new page
they can pop one up in a day and they're
good to go they're super fast and then
same for graphics if someone wants video
advertising who makes video
now another question right is
if they're doing tv commercials
well that's already video that exists
for you to use in youtube and campaign
advertising therefore that's a good
upsell for you to say you know what
you've already got the assets made
let's repurpose them elsewhere and so
understanding how things get created and
again time frames
right now you got to keep them happy on
a month-to-month basis right so how
often are reports created
and these are
things you want to set boundaries
beforehand
how often do they make how often are
reports made what should be in the
reports
how often do you want to talk to them
so if you have a company who wants to
talk to you every single day
are they paying for it right is this
affecting your workflow
it's common to see have some companies
like yeah monthly reports are fine and
then later on it's like but we really
want weekly reports for this product
line
changes your workflow now if you use
something like a data studio where
reports are just auto refreshed they can
run reports on demand right so you've
made it so they have the data they need
they can get it without even asking you
and so sometimes you're looking at
solutions to unburden your time
if you're doing trending
is it month over month year over year
both
right now when do budgets and goals get
re-examined so if you make reports
right which are based upon
how your day-to-day liaison
makes
kpis and consider successful account
you have reports often they get shorter
right as you go up the ladder in the
company for the person who funds the
account
right so
that is the reports that they see
now if they change how they're doing
kpis they change what they want you look
at
how often do you sit down and say should
we re-examine goals or a tech
conversation
how often it do they re-examine their
tech stack
i was running the company a year and a
half ago or so
and um
they really really wanted to get more
into audiences it was a big thing that
on their mind they wanted to do
and their problem was they put in a
ticket about a year earlier to their i.t
team to get their adobe audience manager
data
integrated in their paid search data
and so you know i was like alright let's
just have a meeting with the it team get
an update see how this goes and how we
can we can do stuff
and so we sat down with the marketing
stack team they're like yeah we finished
adobe six months ago you've had that
information
no one knew or i mean this was a giant
company they've had data for like six
months that they didn't even know
existed
so it's not sometimes you are going to
ask questions
that you have to push a little bit
because they may have gotten it done and
don't even know internally this is done
the bigger the company the more likely
it is to happen
right so then we say okay we need a
marketing plan we have all this
background stuff we need a marketing
plan
so marketing plan is usually anywhere
from you know five six pages to
sometimes a hundred plus
it starts with a brief right this brief
is just their name business type goals
goal measurement
so that everyone takes a quick look at
the top of this don't expect the ceo to
read your marketing plan
right but your cmo may glance at the
brief and then go what's not how i want
to measure goals right so you want to
put some of those really important kpi
things
very top so everyone can see it and
that's that only glanced at half a page
that's what they look at so they can say
this is what needs to be changed
now we think about our build
right so
we want to think through what bidding
technology are we going to use
that's a really important consideration
are we going to use google's are we
going to use a third party do we want to
use automation do we want to start
manual move to automation what does it
look like
right geography do we need to
consolidate conversions because we want
to use google's bidtech
right and then
what match types do we use google keeps
changing match types
what are you going to use in the account
right and this again is where you're
going to have those conversations of
here's the overall keyword you want to
use the match types we're using what
this build looks like
what's the at what are the ads look like
um reporting and then you have your
launch versus future and this is common
for both search and display
so i i really like with big accounts
until they have spreadsheets i'm gonna
show example on the next slide
but they'll list out the campaign
settings
the purpose the targeting method and
potentially even different conversions
that are only for that campaign type
then we're going to set the ad groups
right here's the ad groups we want in
each campaign
now in some cases you're going to do
this in google directly you may not
include every ad group in your marketing
plan right sometimes that grows
exponentially so you might just have
things of here's how we're going to make
the ad groups for these particular sets
right same with ad types
and then
landing page updates especially if their
ecommerce students go in and out of
stock what's your feedback loop for
those ad groups so that you know that
these ads need to be paused now or they
can be resumed
at extension usage your bid and budget
your reach and then measurement and so
we'll often have like a spreadsheet it
could be you know really big for for
some accounts and it's really just
here's our name
right here's our budget location
languages networks etc
now campaign names
if it's a small account it's for you
if they're coordinating or you're
coordinating
google and microsoft and various dsps
and so forth across multiple product
lines
you often will have a naming convention
key and you might have some crazy names
but it's really so someone knows this is
you know product a in region a
on on google ads
for these campaign types and here's
goals etc so someone can glance at any
campaign name for
any advertising campaign they're running
and understand what it does
right then so often we sort of start
with you know the typical campaign
settings and then you're just going to
add purpose and notes
and that way if you have like a shared
file system where all the people manage
the account have access to the data they
can pull up the campaign spreadsheet and
they can pull up um the marketing brief
and they can pull up a campaign naming
convention if necessary
and glance at here's the goal here's the
structure
and know exactly what to do and what's
going on right and that's that really
important like five minutes you know
you're on vacation
a call comes in from a client they're
like i need to get up to speed real
quick they can get there
so you know when think of builds builds
are can be all over the place right
there's a lot of ways to accomplish the
the exact same thing with google
so often if we're thinking small budget
and you want to automate it we're
thinking what's you know max conversions
to start
to trend towards target cpa or target
robots right we need some data to begin
with and then we want to rein in the
data with our actual targets
we're often going to see more phrase and
exact match and not broad match
right we're going to use some multi ad
group testing because we don't have huge
amounts of budget and data therefore we
need to use multi-aggregate testing so
that we can get
a better idea and aggregate more
information of how things work
and then
we may overnight use remarketing um
we're marketing in in short term buy
situations doesn't always work the
bigger the company the longer the buying
cycle the more important remarketing is
if for large budget you might start
manual cpc and then move to a target cpa
or loss unless you're using a a marin
kenshu um sa360 so forth a platform for
management
probably again phrase exact and maybe
some broad right once some data comes in
but you're going to then use a lot more
engram analysis
in your
search terms to understand the negatives
to keep reining in the machine as it
expands the broad match
and then you're like oh we're going to
start with remarketing and then we'll in
the future right we'll do some more
audience targeting maybe some discovery
campaigns et cetera
um use multi-aggregate testing non-brand
single for for brand right and these are
just some some easy ways to sort of
start
based on budget size of where you want
to go everyone's been a little different
and so
in case there's maybe a diagram about
someone can understand it right so we
have brand it's impression share bidding
because our goal is 95 percent precious
[ __ ] and we have our top of funnel
keywords we're going to bid you know max
clicks to start we're going to move to
target cpa
but we're going to use a custom
conversion only for those campaigns
where a conversion is a one minute
visitor so we're doing target cpa top of
funnel for engaged users
bottom final i have cpa broads
and then you've got your volatile your
experimental terms could be manual could
be some other or the automated right and
so diagramming can be useful because
accounts can get pretty complicated as
you start
moving cross channels and moving cross
markets
and so this is where that spreadsheet or
diagram can help you understand what's
going on you can layer in you know
budget notes or changes that you know at
the same time just to have that central
data communication place
now before we launch right this is still
planning phases so before we launch
still integration considerations
so maybe someone wants to launch in a
week but they want to use their crm data
so
if their crm isn't salesforce with a or
with a direct plugin back to google ads
you might need to do offline exports to
put in the conversion data into google
ads therefore you need that conversation
of
well we could launch in a week but we
won't have conversion tracking unless
you do x y and z first
and it makes sure everyone knows all the
pieces that must be integrated
um what are used for reporting
conversion tracking so integration is
really key especially if someone is
using you know adobe audience manager
and adobe analytics but they're using sa
360 for bid purposes and they're using
you know third-party feed management for
further stock stuff
that's a lot of different things that
need to talk to each other correctly
so you may even have sort of just a you
know a stack diagram showing here's how
the tech stack works
in this particular account
because if you do all these integrations
and then a year later someone's like hey
yeah we're moving from
adobe analytics to uh google ads
analytics or google ads google google
analytics um what do we need to do and
you haven't looked at this in a year
and you're like okay we have google tag
manager and we have direct integrations
where was this thing connected
right so that can sometimes lead people
to try to fix that or you left the
company and someone else is trying to
figure this out right good luck and so
having just a diagram of tech stack
integrations
really useful to understand how it
changes
then we we understand our integrations
we have conversion tracking in place we
know what we're going to build we go
build the thing
right now we got to launch it and that
the day of truth right you you turn
start on a campaign you unpause the
campaigns things go live and so you want
to start saying
initially you know what is a conversion
rate look like now you're not going to
have data day one for this
right but you're that's something you're
going to watch that first week pretty
close just the overall effectiveness
what you're going to focus on a lot the
first few days
are search terms and grams
initially and then kind of start looking
at quality you won't have data you know
day one and two on quality score but
something you're going to sort of keep
an eye on its trend to know what needs
to be changed
right then you're going to look at the
impression share and the auction
insights that will help you with budget
management did you add too many keywords
and your oppression share is really low
so we could pause some keywords did you
add not enough keyword volume right and
their impression shares are 90 plus
percent and the budget's not being spent
you need to add more keywords or expand
the targeting right so are they going to
hit budget run rates
um what's the analytics look like you
know their bounce rates their time on
site the customer journey
is the audiences that they're getting
and this is now we're talking two to two
weeks to 30 days out of launch right
are the demographic characteristics
equal to
what the user what what the client had
told you on your first conversation
right so are you getting a different
audience completely
if you are getting a different audience
and you have great effectiveness
that tells you hey you did a good job
but b there's a target market that's
still sitting there that hasn't been
reached yet so there's a good expansion
conversation we had about budgets and
reaching that new place
so you you want that definition of a
successful launch
what does it look like and at times a a
complicated launch could take three
months or it may not be we hit unpause
and we're good to go but it may be
staggered here's our search then our
audience remarketing then our dsa and
and so forth they have staggered launch
dates
we watched mark that launched monitoring
but initially we turn it on and we're
like are we getting the search terms we
expect to see
if not we need to adjust keywords or
immediately put negatives into place
right are we spending our budget that
they expect to spend
if you're way under spending early
that's sort of a warning flag to clients
right that you can't you can't do this
so are you spending it correctly
and that's the initial launch stuff like
you're going to look at some of these
way more often the first 30 days then
you might later on i mean you're still
gonna obviously look at this later on
but you might not be really staring at
someone's data quite as much once things
are sort of running in the correct
direction and now you're more steering
the machine and taking advantage of new
opportunities
we have our future plan what's next
right so is it more display
um is it going to be in search is it
going to be in just refinement of what's
actually going on
so people want to know what do you do
for me next right what's the next thing
you can do
so we often start with like sort of like
a checklist right
is goal tracking in place
is there analytics has the account been
built with you know these x things done
double check the campaign settings has
someone double checked the budget
settings
right double check the bids or if you're
using smart bidding on their bid limit
set
right so having just a little checklist
of like yes i've looked at it if there's
multiple people on the team
double look at it have someone else look
at it again and you know double check
mark because you stare enough numbers
it's easy to kind of miss something
sitting there
right and and now you got your account
launched
and now you're gonna you have your times
of when we do client reports
when we revisit goals
when we look back at success metrics to
change things
and how do we expand from there
now
this transition this transitions us to
ongoing management we did another
simpler webinar that has all kinds of
stuff on time and tool management to do
that that overall management it's a
really good video to watch
you know previous webinar we did that
i'll walk through a lot of how to be
organized and do the project management
and so forth within google ads
so to wrap up before some questions
right strategic plans
they they're not sexy they're not this
fun thing they're they're tedious work
but they are crucial
right it it gets you insights from the
advertiser
helps you understand how success is
measured there's a roadmap of what's
created and how to create it and it
shows shows holes in the tracking right
what's not being tracked or everything
is being tracked
right so then we're creating we're
really looking back to the goals the
campaigns the ads and having that
spreadsheet
easy cheat sheet to know what you're
doing
and then we do our launch planning right
have we double checked everything
and by having a plan
right shows the client or the boss that
you they can trust you
right
so when you sit down you talk to someone
yeah we can do that we just create
keywords blah blah blah right that that
tells them you know what you're talking
about
but it doesn't mean you can take all
that information
and make a cohesive thought and strategy
from it
in a marketing plan this shows that you
can think through right how the
advertising should work
and that an important consideration in
trust is
you know a lot of people know a lot of
stuff about paid search
but it's can you marry all the pieces
together in a centralized conversational
manner that you can show to someone
here's your
here's your document for our our launch
here is your marketing plan we're going
to follow here's the places we're going
to adjust the plan based upon your
inputs
but and that really shows that you have
that strategist level right they can't
that they can go to and say hey we
wanted this what do you think as opposed
to the questions of how do we do this
there's button pushing or where options
sort of sits
but plan it but showing these it's good
for career it's good for clients it's
good for client retention um good to
make your boss happy
all right so
let's see if we have
questions on this
comments interesting things
um so forth
you there stuart
i am here
all right the unmute button kept
bouncing i understand how that goes yeah
um so
gary brown has an a question he says you
know
if you have a number of locations if you
restrict them too much
you'll kill the reach of your campaign
are your
some standard theories or practices that
let you
optimize without losing reach
you that's a great question um so
we think of of reach right
we're often not thinking about distance
because people don't think in distance
if i ask you
where's the grocery store right from
your house you're not going to say it's
2.3 miles you're going to say it's a
10-minute drive
so number one it's important to think
about how people think about distance
which actually is time and measurement
not distance measurement now we need to
take that time change the distance for
advertising
but often there there may be areas you
can expand that it's just important to
think about about time reach
um
two
if you're in a small geography and
reaching beyond the geography is gonna
yet get you a bigger reach but you're
not get but they're gonna be totally
unqualified users
right
that so there's there's two ways to
handle that one just don't do it um
that's option one that's you know
clearly and you may open up your other
targeting you may use a little broad
match at times just to expand it
um
if you're doing
manual bidding and you can only do some
manual bidding what we'll see is that
you have a location within a mile your
conversion rate is great within five
miles it drops a little bit within 10
miles it drops some more that they'll do
someone will do concentric circles where
you know within a mile are standard bids
and then they draw a second circle five
miles away well they do a negative bid
adjustment off location and lower bids
you know by by 50 and then you've got
your 10 mile radius bids a little bit
lower and they'll do concentric circle
bidding to be able to still reach
further away but with lower bids because
the the user a little bit less
unqualified
now the second way to do it
is if you are a bunch of small locations
and you're having problems getting words
to show you have all that low volume
stuff and you just need more more places
and this is a big and and
you don't do budget by location
the other option is to add every
location to one campaign
then use an add customizer and you can
use the location add customizer
then just add a location feed so that
the user will always see that location
in the ad itself
and so by adding all the disparate
locations to one campaign you're
aggregating more data which means
keywords can now be active
but you're still doing your your ad
relevance by using add customizers in
the feed itself will not work if you
need budget by location though those are
usually the standards sometimes people
open up the location knowing it won't be
as good um expanded but again if you're
just going to lose money then it that's
often not a great answer so but that's
one of the harder things to deal with in
google is um
low volume because of a very very small
region you're you're advertising in
okay
uh teodora has an interesting question
she asked is it detrimental to campaigns
to not set a goal and how does this
influence campaign performance
you know what so what there's there's
two ways to look at that question so
when you're creating campaigns google
asks you for your goal right what's the
goal this campaign
there is all that does when you select
that is it changes options and stuff
google shows you
so selecting no goal on your campaign
creation
right doesn't affect any performance
things whatsoever
when i think of goals what i'm thinking
of is the conversions we're tracking not
the goals we set in the campaign setup
settings
so if you're not tracking conversions of
course it's detrimental because you
don't want your marketing spenders going
but in campaign creation feel free to
select no goal and not go through all
google soups and
and stuff when you're setting those up
okay
um
uh naveen just has a definitional
question can you elaborate on what roas
uh stands for
oh yeah we're marketing lists for search
ads
so it's you know it's like sorry
r o a s return on advertisements oh oh
yeah rois return on ad spend so that is
just it's a it's a it's a standard
marketing definition of you spent x on
money and you use and you made y off of
that money or wasp is just a percentage
gain so if you
you know if you spent a hundred dollars
advertising and you made a hundred
dollars you have a hundred percent
robust you made what you spent if you
made 300 you have a 300 you tripled your
money some people put it not as a
percentage but as an absolute number the
math is the same
okay
uh danielle
montia has a question
for b to b
what top of funnel conversion
actions might work to help optimize
campaigns
for clients that have long sales cycles
so you've got somebody who's selling it
you know multi-million dollar system
that's going to take a lot of approvals
and that type of thing so
number one white paper download
um no question number two
a
a
document on how to sell it internally a
lot of times right someone wants to do
something but they don't know how to
sell it internally if you walk them
through here's here and even give them
at times presentations on how to sell it
internally um that's great top of funnel
stuff
but white paper is by far the most
common for b2b
okay
that's great advice um
so that means i
just scrolled a little bit the surav
asks
what is
the probability
of finding a job in the field for
someone who's into cloud marketing
who is working as a business development
manager
what are the job opportunities like out
there
someone in
okay so okay job opportunities for
someone in development on cloud stuff
you know uh business development manager
uh in cloud marketing
uh you know what i'm not a specialist
net industry but based upon cloud spend
expenditures and the amount that it's
doing
the the
there's a massive opportunity right now
um
you look at just what you know microsoft
dropbox and amazon have done from a
cloud perspective and oracle's in there
somewhere in the conversation
um and then you look at all the other
things are going on with you know
snowflake and and planter and stuff like
there is just unlimited possibility in
in cloud of business development
management right now it's a matter of
you know sales prospecting and laying it
out but
it's i mean the next five years we're
just gonna see
more and more cloud stuff
uh popping up of how it goes and you
know cloud security is probably the next
one of the next big frontiers
uh great
it's very encouraging um
we have a question
from our linkedin audience ramachandra
asks
um the budget for ppc varies from
organization to organization very
broadly so
what kinds of ranges are typical are
there kinds of rules of thumb
percentage of marketing budget or that
type of thing
no there's none right i wish there was
like yeah 20 of marketing budget goes to
paid right there is zero rules
whatsoever a percentage of marketing
budget that's that's spent on paid
search um this is going to be a
performance look for many companies
we see some companies um paid is their
first or second largest channel by money
they spend
others
especially as you do a lot a lot of tv
advertising pays a smaller percentage
right coca-cola
paid is not a big part of coca-cola
strategy but they're a massive
advertiser
but you get into like an expedia or at
otas paid is one of their top channels
um in in what they spend money on
way more than other places and so
there's not a great answer because it's
a different type of channel and so
many companies are going to have very
different allocations to to paid versus
tv radio print et cetera
okay
um
surya asks how do you identify your
audience by
age cohort and how do you market
differently to different age groups is
that with outside the scope of this
discussion or is that right
no so if you make it so first off um if
you make
in google
and you go to the age section you're
going to see what your current age
ranges are and how they're doing right
and you can add every age range just add
it as an audience they it won't affect
your marketing whatsoever you just get
stats
in some countries you're going to get
very little data um in the u.s we are
roughly 70 percent of people are with a
known age
and at that point in time you're now
going to say okay our age is not unknown
we just can't do anything and then if
you have a lot of known i like to just
trend what's my conversion conversion
rate by age range some cases it doesn't
make a difference
other cases it's a huge difference right
so my favorite example is all this in
like 30 seconds then we'll keep going it
was the beauty of salon who is like
everyone who comes to us is 18 to 24 and
a story just don't even bother
advertising their groups if you do
they're just parents paying for it
and we kept seeing 50 plus converted
incredibly well
and we're like not many especially 65
plus like not many 65 plus of 18 year
olds going to school
and it turned out there's a market they
completely missed which was
semi-retirees going back to get a beauty
school degree to go do part-time work
right they missed it and so there's a
lot of ways you can use that whether
it's you to test out what they told you
or in some cases and they were different
ads of course for that group right
completely different ads if you it's
your career versus second career
and that that'll sort of affect your
marketing and how you speak to each
group
um
bridget thoma has an interesting
question so
there are tons of dependencies in a
corporate structure
from website vendors and video
production vendors and everyone inside
the company
um
how what advice do you have to to
streamlining the
so communications this float
goes better and faster and i
i think from your laughter that this is
something that you wrestle with
yeah so um
i love um steering committee so we i
i've done this three times in the past
three years with a with all with public
fortune 100 companies um is sit down and
say
what other groups that don't talk enough
that are dependent upon each other right
and and like so the one it was
um marketing tech
video
um advertising seo legal
um and
brand and i'm probably missing a group
and once a month the steering committee
sits down and they say here's what we're
doing here's what we're doing exchange
information hey marketing says hey i.t
we're still waiting for this what's
going on that person becomes
their representative represented
internally so that way it's not all
these one-on-one conversations it is a
central representative for marketing nit
it is a central person and legal for
marketing and and vice versa
um
and having that central just here is a
committee that is a single
representative
for those groups for each one who meets
on a regular basis could be just once a
month right
um and that if you need something from x
you know who to talk to and they are
your
advocates in each group i find it's a
tough it's a tough ask
it takes a bit of wrangling especially
to get legal to spend an hour a week in
a marketing meeting
um but it is a huge win when it's done
okay
um
we don't don't have time for any more
questions and we have so many here but
um
i want to pick out a couple and i
apologize to anybody whose question i
don't get to but tabism has an
interesting question
he worked for a small business recently
and
he was just stunned by the higher cost
uh
ctr costs and and um
or the click-through rate i'm sorry um
but
very low conversions on the landing page
so you get a lot of clicks and very few
conversions
and how do small businesses
deal with a problem like that so they
can
actually use
google
to generate
so
generally if you're seeing a lot of
clicks and few conversions in an smb
right then there's there's a few
different things to look at um one
are the keyword specific enough
i i see a lot of times a plumber will
use a keyword like you know plumber or
pipes
most people searching pipes aren't
looking for a plumber to go fix
something so is the targeting itself
specific enough
um are the negatives being used the
keywords being used correctly um number
two does the website work across every
device type is it mobile phone friendly
is it um
is it desktop friendly
number three
is it easy to convert right so not just
forms and captures no one can read but
is the phone number a click to call
phone number if it is a lot of
businesses get more calls than they
realize from google um but they're not
tracking phone numbers right and if
that's important are you using you know
click to call add formats and call out
formats and call extensions
um
and so that good website do you have
those trust elements in place right so
you look at real and find go find a site
that looks really good in your industry
this kind of model from or or maybe even
an aggregator right if you're in
you know uh you go look like service
master right that's their big aggregator
of smb services then
what do their pages look like to do that
easy trust and then lastly are you
showing your local
i was recently um i did this yesterday
someone was like here's this cool
convention
that you know and it was a small
business doing it locally right and i'm
like i wonder where it is
i couldn't find an address so they would
they taught this is the name of the
venue but i didn't know the name so i
don't even know where they're located so
is it easy to figure out where you are
what your reach is do you visit
someone's area and and is that on the
website plain english or plain whatever
language local language it is um you
know it's those things that make a big
difference because cpcs you get into
locksmiths and stuff the cpcs are crazy
high
the conversion rates are two
so do you answer the question and make
it easy to do business with you
just usually those types of things will
make a big difference for an smb account
okay
a couple more questions uh before we
wrap up uh depending how asks a really
interesting question
can a ppc campaign be auto targeted and
auto managed
for the target customer behavior
like a mutual fund manages money of
investors
in other words can you can you set up
a lot of automation
um
so uh yeah but a mutual fund you've got
someone looking over making adjustments
right mutual fund they're always like do
i need to sell this do i need to buy
this what's the peony ratios and ffos of
various companies of how we move stuff
around so it's etfs our efts are are
usually automated on balancing scales
right mutual funds aren't but um
regardless
you can use a lot of rules and
automation if the humans looking over it
so things never to automate um negative
keywords
right so
we'll see at least every other months or
every three months someone will automate
negative keywords and like google had a
hiccup recently with conversion tracking
their brand becomes all negatives
because there was a conversion tracking
problem never want to automate negatives
um can you automate looking at search
terms that hit a certain criteria making
them keywords absolutely can you
automate bidding absolutely should you
automate ads no way because that's your
connection point that is what marketing
is persuading it's going to take action
should not automate the ad part
i'm human should think about that but
can you do a lot of automation that sits
there to make it so the human is doing
specific tasks and and looking at more
of creative side absolutely
okay
um
onage asks if there's a checklist
or parameters that you use
to reduce cost per click or optimize
cost per click
you know i mean
not necessarily so
when you're you're the cpc
in a way is irrelevant
it is what is the cost per conversion or
the roast compared to what your goal is
if i'm paying 500 a click and every
click's a conversion and my target cpa
is 500
yes i can work on quality score i could
reduce the bid and get less traffic but
in reality it's hitting my goals
so it's not just about the cpc right
it's really more about this the cost per
acquisition the the return on ad spend
or the profit metrics that are way more
important
and then you you often can reduce cost
per clicks by adding negative keywords
get rid of relevant queries i'm working
on quality score to increase cost or
reduce the cpc
but you do have some levers that exist
in that
but it shouldn't be about always
reducing cpc
it should be about getting more
conversions at a target cpa
one last question um before we have to
wrap up
um tabosum asks
how do you deal with
the false clicks or click fraud
um
are there
products that that can help automate
that
um you know it's filtering that out
sure so one
it's worth looking at so google has an
invalid click report that will show you
clicks you did not pay for
um which is sort of an important initial
aspect google's gotten
really good at at managing invalid
clicks on on a pattern basis um if
you're spending 500 or a thousand
dollars a month the tools are
usually too expensive for what you get
in return
if you're spending hundreds of thousands
a month then there are good tools you
can use um that will
some will just give you here's here's
potential
fraud clicks others will do direct
connections to request refunds on your
behalf
it's important to know the business
rules of what they consider fraud
i remember one of the first times i
worked with such a tool they were like
all this traffic is fraud and they gave
this huge list of section of fraud and
that fraud had it was like 11 conversion
rate and i was like i want more of this
fraud this is awesome traffic right and
they had a business rule that if they
couldn't determine country of origin for
a click it was automatically fraud
but for a international advertiser that
often happens in in some places like
africa where there's some some weird
driven lines or where countries are or
areas where you get into small countries
like netherlands and belgium where
someone may be in one country they
actually appear to be from the second
one
and so
you must know their business rules
because you're you're going to use their
data to tell google that something was
wrong and you deserve money back
so understand how it's done
before you let the man as part of that
relationship as well
i mean there's not many tools for it
wonderful um
so that's all the time we have for
questions and answers i do apologize for
not
being able to get to all of them but we
do have
a huge number here and i will um
pass those on to brad afterward and see
if we can get some things that we can
share with the audience in the future
follow-up or a future webinar
um
and we've also got a number of questions
we will be sending out a follow-up email
to this webinar you'll receive it
tomorrow and it will have a link to the
recording of this session
as well as a couple of handouts that
brad
has prepared to help you with strategic
planning so with that i want to move on
to the
second poll
last one of the day
and
this asks what
areas of
digital marketing are you most
interested in learning more about
adding to your repertoire adding to your
toolkit
so it will take another
30 seconds or so and the second part of
the question is
oh
and i don't have it loaded
i apologize for that
we did it normally have a second part of
the question which asks when you want to
get started but
i apologize for not having that one
okay in
three two one
so seo and ppc
uh other plurality
followed by social media
but also website conversion content
marketing all across the board
and
so
when we follow up we'll share with you
information about
offerings from simple learn to help you
in all of those areas
and in the meantime
i think that concludes the webinar so
thank you
brad
i thank you stuart for managing it we
really should add analytics to this poll
yes
i will do that in future editions um
and what i'm going to do now is i'm
going to
take back
screen sharing and i will
give you a moment here
should i stop screen sharing to make it
easier for you to switch over
uh
no we're okay i will be able to do that
from the side
and
okay and i will share my screen
ah
use me for this
there we are
so i want to thank you brad um
for
a really
engaging and
um
informative
masterclass that
generated like i said a ton of questions
and um that's always a good sign that
the audience is very interested in what
you had to say so thank you for that
well thanks for hosting us it's a good
group
okay and thank you everybody for being
here
i will mention
um
and i've dropped this into the chat once
or twice
okay here we go
we do have a postgraduate program in
digital marketing covers not
pretty much all of the
topics that were in that second poll
um so i'll drop a link to that into the
chat again
before we sign off
and i'll also mention that we have a
career webinar coming up next tuesday
november 23rd
with vanicola the managing director of
kalari capital one of india's
leading venture capital firms
and it's part of our ambition cannot be
locked down
program
this one is about how top professionals
thrive through the pandemic
um as we've all seen this has been a
period that's disrupted all of our lives
but
a lot of people have done really well
and advanced their careers
even in the face of lockdowns and other
challenges so
vonnie will talk about the the
entrepreneurs and
new company startups that have
accomplished this and and the
professionals that she works with
so uh i will also put a link to that
into the chat
and
then we invite everybody to connect with
us through our social media channels our
handles are at simply learn on facebook
and twitter
and simply learn at linkedin
so
with that i'm going to conclude
the webinar but please do check the chat
briefly
in a couple moments to see all these
links i've talked about and
thank you so much
for being here
you